what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch the
next episode of gravity falls episode 13
of season two john
say it is dungeons dungeons and more
dungeons that's right kiddos we are
going to do this today leave a like we
are almost done with this series and
then goodbye to all animated shows
permanently on the channel
permanently don't take that with any
sarcastic hints at all
100 sincere also uh full-length reaction
watch long as we sync up with the time
code or over at uh patreon.com blindwave
so we'll see you guys there thanks
prepper help us edit down these videos
lazy tuesday you are delivering in a big
way
yeah it's nice to finally have a day
where nothing interesting happens
whatsoever
yeah
[Music]
everyone get down don't let it taste
human flesh
whatever can we keep it shh magorith
[Music]
great now get it out of here smells like
if death could barf ew on the dark weird
road i travel i'm afraid you cannot
follow
well call me for dinner
next time then number one fan the season
finale of ducktective is airing this
friday that's all the mystery you need
this week come on quack with us dipper
quack quack
quack quack just let goose
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're a silly goose mabel ducking
hilarious did you guys know that the
last episode uh they aired it originally
with no commercial breaks i didn't learn
that from anyone in the comments
i learned it all on my own
just came to you and if you guys
contribute nothing to the comments
dear mom and dad we've been in gravity
falls for a few months and so much has
happened so they are alive yeah let the
rebuilding of the town begin wrecking
ball start wrecking things
oh wow
it's my favorite fantasy talking level
counting statistics and graph paper
involving game of all time dungeons
dungeons and more dungeons do you want
to play it with me well i do like
unicorns and that hot elf looks
promising how do you play the rules are
simple
first you roll a 38-sided diet to
determine the level of each player's
statistical analysis
relate directly to the amount of
quadrant that your team has dominion
over which is inverse to the
anti-quadrants in your
upper little game of d and d and more d
oh sorry dipper i don't go in for that
pen and paper kind of stuff i'm more of
an f-clarper uh what
f-clorp foam and cardboard legitimate
outdoor role-player
nice when facing yawn adversaries shield
thyself under an elfin buttress
i say it again
buttress
hey
laugh all you want structural comedy you
rolled a 17.
oh this is sad maybe i should start
obsessing over wendy again uh hey give
it back come on gompers
that's gonna be like jumanji man my 38
sided die
this is nothing like jumanji
[Laughter]
wait is that a 38-sided die from
dungeons dungeons and more dungeons got
yourself a playmate know that game
with pen and paper shield and sword our
question
[Laughter]
my boy
do you know what this means
we must stop everything i've been
working on at once
and why
[Music]
even human flesh it's going to leave a
mark
okay i think we've got everything we
need to watch the season finale of
detective tomorrow i even made mouth
ramps so we can pour food into our
mouths without taking our eyes off the
screen
i love it i want it i recreated the main
character addison's fair taxes
quack quack i'm the duck detective who
stole my bread loaf
that is so messed up dipper would love
that
yeah oh no oh no
an illusion cast by probabilitor the
annoying
you know his weakness right prime
statistical anomalies over 37 but not
exceeding 51.
yes oh in your face you cardboard oh no
thankfully you missed the period when
the creators of the game tried to make
it cooler
man this
an
infinity-sided die oh no
wow if i rolled it anything could happen
our faces could melt into jelly the
world could turn into an egg or you
could just roll an eight oh no
spending a lot of time with the old
fordsy lately huh you have no idea i
knew the author must be cool but he's
better than i imagined and he doesn't
make fun of me all the time the way you
and grunkle stan do yeah
hello
now you got me
she have a floppy disk on her shirt oh
yeah it's one of her classic looks i
don't think i've ever noticed it
someone's all dressed up it's a big
night
i think we all remember where we were
when we learned ducktective was shot
who shot ducktective we ran out of room
in the basement and we're going for a
world record now dice
32 yes 7 000
damage oh why why with this
hey at least i'm not all keyed up to
watch a kid's show i'll have you know
the ducktective has a big mystery
element and a lot of humor that goes
over kids heads i don't get a lot of it
listen stanley did it ever occur to you
that if you joined us you might actually
have fun what now you listen to me as
long as i live i will never uncle stan
wait ever stanley lay your smarty pants
nerd gang no
it's gonna be like jumanji
[Music]
portals of dimension 46 apostrophe
backslash kneel before me and
snivel
ugh you are the smartest players i've
ever met that's why i'm going to eat
your brains to gain your intelligence
freeze them
your math is no match for my gun you
idiot madre
oh no
i'm not here to play games
now to the forest for the ultimate game
the room's free now
who wants to watch ducktective
nobody
more couch for granda
it's like 22 minutes come on make it
happen everyone grab a weapon
oh nice
[Music]
yeah
he must complete seven unworldly quests
each more difficult than the now
[Laughter]
he's magic sweetie i'm sure he's fine
there's no cops in the forest we take
this to our graves
you're life packed now granddad you must
defeat me
in dungeons dungeons and more dungeons
real life edition
[Music]
oh no my ears they're so pointy there
better be something protective under
this tunic
oh no there isn't dippers
balls free fall of difference
this game involves math but also risk
and imagination risk
imagination
make something up it's just like lying
lie stand live build of shielding
ha we're doing it shield of shielding
reversal spell
oh my god that all you have to say
coming to the sci-fi channel
[Music]
how loud i was expecting i am so
confused and so proud right now
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
he can only be defeated by rolling a
perfect 38. all right stan you can do
this
papa needs a new pair of twins
[Applause]
all your smarts are no match for dumb
death
lucky
death muffins
[Music]
oh is like over excelsi whatever
now
i'm returning to my own realm i'm
turning
[Music]
you can watch the into showing of
ducktactiv it's not too late
the only person clever enough to defeat
duct tective is
detective oh
[Music]
you had a twin brother all along that's
the big twist we were waiting for what a
ripoff i predicted that like a year ago
ah meta
i dismantled the portal an
interdimensional gateway is too
dangerous for the world it feeds into
the instability of the machine created
this an interdimensional rift oh
my time i've made many powerful enemies
but i trust you with this secret oh
now get yourself to bed good night great
uncle ford
good night dipper
dipper's going to say something
[Music]
does anyone want to rescue him i'm kind
of kind of tired
out for a long day long day f
don't step to the wizard cause the
wizard don't play night
that's what's up dude that guy's dead
now that's what's up i got eaten by a
hippogriff by griffin that's what's up
that's what's up
all right john yo what'd you think aha
what's your favorite episode of all time
my all-time favorite episode oh you know
what's funny this episode and like
seeing stranger things across four
seasons and a bunch of other things i've
never played dungeons and dragons once
in my life and i feel like i ought to at
some point oh my god you'd be great at
it would i i don't know i feel like part
of me feels like you know the the part
of me that likes imagination and like
ooh like coming up with weird things and
telling story like at that part but like
the rest of like the structuring and the
hierarchy of rules and [ __ ] i feel like
might
be uh overwhelming oh it's don't get me
wrong it's the most boring thing in the
world
but you'd be great at it if you played
dude
one day we'll do a live stream and we'll
play no i actually got um invited to
play
not this next saturday oh wow invited to
play with a group of people who play
every weekend oh like you love it i'm
telling you and i'm like i know i know i
love it why don't you just shut up and
let me play
dude you're gonna have to report back i
have no idea how to play dungeons and
dragons
no no no clue like i i don't understand
what they do in shows
to me they're just saying words
i have a feeling
for whatever reason i feel like whatever
we see in shows is not exactly
representative of what it's actually
like because it was like i feel like
they have to take the most visually
engaging parts
yeah which are probably not the whole
game but this was a sweet tender episode
twas
do you have an uncle you really bond
with john
um i don't get to see my uncles very
often but i have uh two i have three two
uncles on my mom's side i have an uncle
on my dad's side and i get on with them
each in different ways i probably see my
uncle tom the most
and uh you know he's a good dude we get
on we laugh we got a movie taste and
stuff like that i don't know i share
something different with each of my
uncles that's nice yeah my uncle dan i
share music with and uh my uncle greg is
like
really chill dude you know you don't
hear from him as much but he's like a
really chill dude he's got a cool like
garage man cave thing we used to hang
out in back when we used to take trips
out there so yeah he also took me on my
first motorcycle ride which was very
very cool he's he's a very cool dude
each one's a little different but uh
cool uncles does your experiences with
either your uncle tom or your uncle greg
help you connect with what dipper's
going through here
yeah they both make fun of me a lot and
uh you know
we uh when he played no it's stanford
two of two out of the three make fun of
me a lot so no which one is the african
yeah which one's
the real stanford is ford is jake
yeah
yeah yeah and then stan lee's stanford
doesn't make fun of dipper
no that's true he just pushes him away i
guess that would be maybe
i guess maybe the best
stand-in would be my uncle tom i don't
know
it's not a good to one here
you know what i mean no
but yeah i mean he would be the one
probably who like you know he's a doctor
so he's got the most sort of like
scientifical background but he's also
like super uh
just like really open to things and
really sort of like fun and welcoming
not to suggest that my other uncles
aren't but he's like especially just
sort of kind of
warm and fun so uh so yeah i guess he
and i would wind up playing some kind of
weird game and figuring that out
i thought these answers would be more
interesting i know right
aren't you happy i yes answered these
questions
you know
getting real
i miss my uncles i haven't seen any of
them in a few years
and my aunts and my nieces and stuff
because i feel terrible
it's okay
so listen this episode
i'm sorry my life doesn't match the show
well now
yeah this was this was a this was a a
sort of sweet uh
but also i don't know thrilling like i
like the dipper and
ford getting to kind of bond i thought
the way they orchestrated that was fun
and natural the way he kind of finally
does agree like okay i'm going to tell
you about some of this don't tell
anybody you know
it's a natural
progression
i thought your feedback would be more
interesting
i just want to grab a sword and go out
in the woods and hit some stuff you know
let's fight you want to fight
let's fight right now no not at all god
you know how what's the most science on
a device you've ever had i need a knot i
need to get rid of my phone
oh yeah that would help
i didn't run away okay
i think it's time yeah
move to like a cabin in the woods
someplace remote get a job working at a
general store
no social media
i think i just need to
like go under a freeway that's too far
okay i want to do more work oh yeah
you'll hide in plain sight that way
yeah
he'll still be thinking it's time the
time has come
but yeah him bonding with four to
getting to see this side of four which
is very childlike and um
you know i think about
playing with kids and trying to
kids now you know like me just bonding
with little kids random kids not me
thinking about kids in the future
just kids now bonding with them and how
i would play with them
that's what i'm talking about
kids in the future uh
kids in the future like having to meet
at their level
bond with them
over such activities
that require the imagination because as
you get older it's easier to tense up
when you try to be playful around people
yeah you know you try to be cool flex
your tries
this is how i opposite playfulness is
how
does
i
flirt
to show my masculinity i want to read my
fanfic
yeah that's why john doesn't have
triceps i know
imagination i don't imagine anything so
i don't have my triceps you don't need
muscles john don't worry i need all the
muscle your hair is your biggest muscle
your hair is the most uh here what is
that
now your skin is your biggest organ
there you go that's that's what i was
that's what weird reference i was
reading your organ is oh that's right my
bad i forgot about the organ
jeez
embarrassing
um
yeah that's me i i like uh i thought
this was a lot of fun the duck detective
thing is
that was amusing i did find myself going
i want to see a whole episode of
ducktective
that seems like it'd be a hilarious time
and off
and uh i like how they brought the game
to life at the end that was very
imaginative
and horrific at times and throughout
this episode with the creatures and even
like the stapling that ducked together
like uncle stan did that was so gross
and so funny
what a morbid joke that was a disgusting
joke i love it love it so much i love
the messed up humor yes yeah absolutely
and then this one like threw down on
both
some of that and also like the very meta
just uh you know we're gonna directly
comment on ourselves not just not just
about child what was the bit not just
the bit at the end where they're
obviously like oh he's got a twin
brother but there was something else
that kind of scratched that itch in a
more clever way it'll come back to me
it's the bit where grunkle stan an adult
defends watching a show ostensibly for
kids because it's got a surprise mystery
elements and a lot of jokes that go over
kids heads oh yeah and shouts out to
weird al it's fun to hear weird al doing
a doing a gravity falls voice like
perfect cartoon for him to be in so it
was nice anyway
guys
do you like dungeons and dragons
do you care
does it sound boring to you
what what class of character are you
oh
z
that's definitely a classic the one
where you get all the chicks in the
village man that's right you're a z
you're a ninth level z make up your own
rules and dungeons and dragons
that's this i it sounds
it sounds like there's such a scope of
possibility that it sounds overwhelming
i'm going to be very competitive when i
play with my friends and people as i'm
learning
did they guarantee you that they're
going to do like a a one-day story line
or something like that i don't know what
you're talking about what all i know is
when i go in there i'm winning the vague
thing sure sure sure yeah no and when i
said that they're like
yeah i guess you can win
like what is this game
this doesn't sound like a game worth
playing point you can't win
yes you can win what does that mean
yeah well let me know how it goes it's
good anyway look we're gonna do a page
tyler hague hey i feel like you'd be a
perfect person to play
d and d with you're already so good at
video games
i can imagine that you
could
really be like you know if you were to
be a character in one of these role play
games i imagine you would be
like a troll you know
like oh my god the terrifying troll
coming through the village
here stampeding through our homes but
then you find out that this troll is
actually a gentle soul
one that just is trying to protect what
was he trying to do he was trying to
play with a butterfly but as we was
chasing this butterfly just a couple of
homes got in the way and a couple of
children ended up getting squashed under
his foot
but we learned forgiveness although it's
the times we live in and we don't
forgive in a large enough quantity yeah
so then you're imprisoned
and then you are beheaded with your body
slowly to be burnt
across a river of wood where they shoot
arrows with flames at the end of them
and then you perish to be forgotten as
an evil
evil
fairy tale
but only couple
knew
that really just how sweet and plain
tyler was a playful troll you got to
play as an adult you know
so it's unfortunate that this should
happen to you
i really thought would you contribute
there would be more
let's interesting it back to the whole
review back to the top tyler
i'm so sorry
you yeah
[Music]